You all liked my last video so much! :)
Thank you I appreciate that :)
So let me tell you some more
Let me tell you about my childhood
Let me tell you about how I grew up
Where I came from, what I did before I did Youtube
Well
I played Tibia
Best fucking game :#
And boy, do I have some stories
There's some things I didn't say in my last video
because I just thought it was, it was too much
Too much to share
You're just going to judge me completely for the rest of my life
So I wanted to tell you about the worst thing I've ever done to someone
Which was through this game Tibia
Cause this game
You could fuck around with
It's like, it's like an MMO with no restrictions
Not like nowadays, you play
I don't know, League? And you get banned for toxic behavior?
Why don't you grow some balls, how 'bout that?
What is going to happen to our future generation?
These pussy ass games
Alright, Tibia, you can do whatever the fuck you want, alright
The only way you could get ban, if you were cheating
Actually, if you were caught cheating
(see what I did there)
Or, if you killed too many people at once, okay?
Which was really fucking cool by the way cause there was this one spell called
Ultimate explosion
And if you got really pisssed
You hit that button, the whole screen fucking explode
Everyone dies and you get instant ban and you're like
Sunglasses just comes out and you're like, Fuck Yeah
Then you cry cause you got banned but whatever
Tibia is the kind of game that doesn't explain shit to you
But somehow people managed by
JUST FINE. Okay?
We don't need hand holding
When you start playing, you start off at Rookguard which is this newbie island
What it's called
And eh, you start killing rats
If you know what you're doing, it shouldn't take more than
a couple hours to get out of Rookguard
Because once you get to level 8
You get to talk to The Oracle, and you get to decide
what class you want to be and you get to the main land
Where most of the action is
You don't want to stay in Rookgaard
You want to get the fuck out, as soon as possible
Now it should only take you a few hours to get out of Rookgaard
For me the very first time, it took 3 fucking weeks
The game doesn't explain shit, okay?
It's so fucking confusing
You start killing rats with your fists and you're like
I don't, I don't think this is it
You get trapped by fucking rats in this fucking cage and you're like
God damn it this is so humiliating
And then, when you're done with the game, you lose a level
So it's just- it brings even more fucking time okay
Oh, and there were holes
There were these fucking holes in the game
You go out, you go down to find creatures or whatever
Now everyone just wants to get the fuck out of Rookguard as soon as possible
You really just fight for
Finding the spawns okay, the monsters
you want to kill as many as possible
You don't want other people to get the experience
So you go down these fucking holes
There's always a ladder, so you can get back up
Well, if you go a little too far
Or in the wrong fucking hole
THERE'S NO LADDER
And you're like what the hell? What do i do?
How am I suppose to get up?
And you start yelling cause you can yell in the game
Like HELP!
I'M STUCK
There's no audio in the game but if you hit this button
It might, it might show a text for someone who is nearby
Outside screen
Now people would see it, and they would come down and they're like
Well shit
Now we're both stuck down here
So I would, I would tell my friend to start a new character
Buy a rope, you needed a rope for some fucking reason
By this specific guy, for 50 gold
Which was a lot of money
So your friend had to get the rope
Find the specific spot that you were in
And rope you up
That's how you got out
Now when we discovered this we were like, well
Clearly
50 eh, 50 gold that's a lot of money
I think, I think we can make some money back on this
So we would, we would trick people
To go down the same hole
And then we would go down with them and they would be like
Shit I can't get up can you help me
And then I will just be like BLEEP, BLEEP, BLEEP, BLEEP
Going up and down and be like OH, OH
There's a problem here?
Oh I would love to help you but you know
ROPES
ROPES ARE EXPENSIVE
And they're like okay 50G
If you rope me up, I'm like okay I will accept your money
And your helmet
Then they're like NO
NO I'm not gonna pay you, it's 50G okay
I know the rope and I'm like well
It's either that or you're gonna be fucking stuck here
AND NOW YOU KNOW WHAT? I WANT YOUR ARMOR TOO
I KNOW YOU HAVE ONE
Oh... so funny
So we would, we would keep tricking people to go in
Now this wasn't that bad, it was just a fun thing to do
It was a fun thing, out of many things you can do in the game
Fuck people over
It was a lot of stuff you can do to fuck around with people in Tibia
For example, if you wanted to trade an item with someone
Well let's say a giant sword, that's a really expensive item in the game
I don't remember, maybe like 25k?
But what's funny about the giant sword is
It looks very similar
To a two-handed sword
Which isn't worth shit, alright?
So what you would do is, you find someone who wants to buy a giant sword
And you would trade them the giant sword
And they would trade in the gold
And right before you click accept
You cancel, and then you write ''Oops, sorry''
TRADE ME AGAIN
And then you trade in
But this time, the two-handed sword
And you click okay
They click okay without looking, beacuse they looked so similar
AND BAAM
You got yourself 25k and you piss someone up in the process
That was a thing about Tibia
If you were higher level than someone
They were your bitch
But anyone higher level than you
You were their bitch
But there was also the constant fear and terror
And paranoia, that you would fuck with someone lower level
That had a friend
Cause everyone had a fucking higher level friend okay
And it was the worse thing
But there was one thing that happened
That was probably too far
Probably we took it a little
Little too far
Now let me tell you what it is
It's the worst thing I ever done to someone
Here we go
Since Tibia was so popular in Sweden where I grew up
People would write on like eBay
The Swedish eBay
To buy specific items, for real money
So I found someone that was interested in buying an item that I had
And I thought well that's, that's kinda funny
I'll, I'll accept that trade
Hey, I'll take real money
So I would tell him to meet me up at a net cafe
Because we lived in the same city
And erm... to make this trade
But the thing was
The thing was that
We had installed a key logger on the computer
Which basically means we could get his password and log in
So we would meet him up, and that guy was fucking old
Like he was way older than me, he was probably 18
And I'm like what, Jesus Christ there's no way I can go through with this
This is gonna, this is gonna fucking KILL ME
But I just went through with the trade because
I didn't want to fucking die
So I got my money, he got his item
And then we were off our own way
But then I realised
I still had his log
It was right you know, it was right there
It was- it would be like- they would be like
It's theft not to take it
Okay
I log in
And I sent my item back
So basically I, it's just like theft
Pretty much, I assume this is like robbery
I took my item back
But the thing was like, my friends were with me
We didn't
Just take back our item
We took all his items
And you think I might be done
Okay, you may- you may think I crippled this guy enough
And if you're watching, the guy that we did this to
I am sorry, okay?
I don't know what was wrong with me
But we thought it would be funny
To kill his character
So he would go back
To Rookgaard, the newbie level
But we killed him, an ungodly amount of times
Till he got to level 8
And he was sent back to Rookgaard, the newbie island
With no items
And no dignity
It's like if, if
You wanted to kill someone
You wouldn't just kill them
You would first- you would cut off their limbs
And cut off their balls, and send them into the fucking ocean
That's pretty much what we did to this guy''s character
I can't even imagine just
Having this character that you worked so hard on
And then log in one day and you're back in newbie island
You know I still got nightmares, okay?
I realised this was a pretty terrible thing to do
I uh, I apologise
Okay?
If you're watching now, I am sorry
But it was really funny at that time
Everyone was pretty much an asshole, for playing this game
I mean there were some, there were some white knights, quite literally
As well, but I think anyone who had fun with this game
Was an asshole in this game
So yeah, that's some more Tibia stories for you
It's the game that I grew up with in my childhood
I was really entertained by reading what you guys
Childhood games were as well
So leave a comment and leave a like if you want more stories like this
I really enjoy making them
And as always
Stay awesome bros
Please don't judge me, too much okay?
Listen, I was young
I didn't know any better